hi guys I'm Tamara chambers and this is
episode 4 of Tamara's never seen and
tonight I am going to watch The Goonies
people have been commenting like asking
are you serious this is a lie she's
definitely seeing this because I'm
watching movies that everyone has seen
before and first of all that's the point
of the show is I've never I've not seen
anything I grew up with like Star Wars
and Indiana Jones and like animated
Disney movies
I wasn't introduced into these really
cool but weirder genres I was also born
in 1991 and so I missed all the 80s like
by the time I was old enough to like
comprehend movies like hey there's a
different things were coming at and I
know like a lot of the viewers are like
younger and they still have seen these
things I don't know guys I don't know I
did see him alright I'm sorry I'm so
sorry so here we go Oh cameras never
seen you guys that was so much fun okay
I have to say I wasn't imagining that I
would love that as much as I did or that
I was even going to like enjoy it it's
like the most 80s movie I've ever seen
in my entire life
yes yep The Goonies is the most 80s
movie I've ever seen it opens with this
really awesome like jail escape and then
there's a police chase and then there's
an awesome introduction to each of the
children and he's looking out of his
window and he's like oh nothing exciting
ever happens here but it's gonna be so
something I noticed right off the bat is
there's a lot of advertising and I think
that's just an 80s thing like I think it
wasn't off-putting for them to have like
in the first scene there was like Pepsi
and there was like a Mad Magazine and
there's like a purple Ranger and like
not the purple rains advertising but you
know what I mean like like blatant like
brands and now it just doesn't happen
that way so then you see chunks who is
the token fat guy who I feel bad for for
being you know the token fat guy
got stuck on my lipgloss see that I did
two jokes in one the advertising joke
and a fat joke was her hair flip so she
didn't know anyways I was really
distracted by their elaborate like
mousetrap awesome super cool way to get
into their gate at the front door chunk
is like let me Olivia and then like they
drop I don't know I think it's like a
bowling ball and then goes like down
some levers and then like into a chicken
coop and the chicken lays an egg and
that like offsets something and like the
gate opens and by the way it's like a
two-foot gate so like he definitely
gonna hop she's a gate but it's like no
no got me in the special way which I
understand then their other friend like
zip lines across over what it seems like
electrical wires it's probably not maybe
it is it's the 80s who knows so he zip
lines in through the window crashes
through like their screen door the mom
comes in she's just like well I see he's
arrived and like knows exactly what's up
cuz she's a cool mom she's not one of
those lame moms he doesn't let people
break her screen door every time they
come over she's a cool mom so then you
see the kid whose nickname is mouth and
he can speak perfect Spanish like there
is no way he's learning this in middle
school Spanish like I took three years
of Spanish in high school and all I can
say is donde esta el baño
so then the mom leaves with the
housekeeper and they all decide to
explore the Attic for the first time
ever and there's like a ton of really
cool shit out there they find this map
and they're like well I guess we should
find the stricture couple and it all
happens very fast and it's a little
rushed but also I imagine watching this
as a kid and just being blown the actual
fuck away like wanting something like
that's so badly so then you find out
that the house is in foreclosure and
that's why they're moving oh yeah that's
why they went to the attic to pack
things up I'm pretty sure it makes sense
in my mind so I think that's what
happened but anyways the house is in
foreclosure and they decide that if they
find this treasure then they can save
their home and all of a sudden this
story makes sense and it's full and
there's things happening I really enjoy
the childlike
optimism of like oh there's a treasure
map and I'm sure people have been
looking at for this for like decades but
we're gonna go find it right now on our
bikes and it's gonna be in our
neighborhood and they do obviously
spoilers I guess you've all seen this
but they absolutely find the trip and I
think that's hilarious like oh people
have been searching for this for decades
and a bunch of little boys like go and
search for maybe two hours and they find
the treasure yeah America I don't know
why that's America but it just is it's
so 80s so they're following the map and
where the treasure should be is this
lighthouse cafe place and the bad guys
from the beginning who escaped from jail
are in there then they find this insane
monster chained up in the bottom of the
basement and you find out it's sloth and
he's the brother of the bad guys and
it's really horrifying
and really fucked up that's like I show
rain it's like why are you there why
what what huh okay something a little
inconsistent with the character of Mikey
who's like the main boy is like he's
sometimes he's really like nerdy and
they were up in his basement or up in
his basement tear the paper up in his
attic and he was like you guys don't
touch anything no my mom said we can't
do that blah blah blah and then he's
like down in the basement
finding sloths and everyone's scared
he's like you guys it's fine calm down
it's totally cool it's just a giant man
monster who's chained up in the basement
of this bad guy layer fill out so they
hear the bad guys coming down into the
basement they don't want to get caught
and so they leave they find this place
underneath the fireplace and they all go
and they leave chubs
in the freezer with the dead guy for the
bad guys to find that's not
not kind so while the bad guys are
capturing chubs everyone else the entire
rest of the party who two girls have now
added to the party they're like oh we
like you're the big brother so we're
gonna come or one of them does that not
both of them this isn't like a Sister
Wives thing it's not too weird of a
reference I don't know I chopped up
what's cool anymore guys and they end up
in the bottom of a wishing well and then
this amazing scene happens where the
jock guy of the school who you only see
one other time like the rows of coin in
the wishing well and he's hanging out at
the top of the wishing well with his
friend cuz that's cool place to hang out
it's where the popular people hang out
is bushy well his other jerk friend is
like what you wish for man he's like I'm
gonna have Stokes with Andy she's like
the love interest of everyone and they
like high-fiving oh yeah man Wow sex and
wishes awesome so they're all down there
trying to get out and data like catches
the coin that he throws out and throws
it back up at him to get his attention
and he catches it and he looks down and
sees them all and he looks up at his
friend he's like wishes do come true
they like high-five explosions happen
it's no explosion it's like what do you
celebrate Amy you did not just do you
don't know what sex is oh okay like high
school is definitely gonna be his best
years of his whole life and then they
all decide they want to stay in the well
and keep searching for the treasure the
bad guys finds the under-under basement
and they find the kids and there's this
chase scene that's pretty cool and all
of the kids find this like entrance to
the supposed to treasure and it's just
really cool like grand organ made out of
bones and they have to play a song to
get through to the next part and they
find music notes on the back of the map
which I thought was really cool and they
make it through and they all go down
this amazing waterslide and there's this
giant fucking pirate ship and they go in
the pirate ship and there's fucking
treasure galore and it's so exciting I
can't watching this as a kid must have
been the coolest thing I would have
pretended to be these boys every day of
my life with my little brother but the
bad guys can
them again and like force them out of
the ship and like make them walk the
plank then they trip some booby traps
and it's very frightening giant CGI
rocks fall from this guy so it's pretty
suspenseful this is really sweet
sloth helps them escape and in doing so
traps himself inside the cave and the
kids are out and they're on the beach
and they find their parents and they're
all reunited and it's a really cool
ending one thing that's kind of a weird
complaint but that I noticed happen a
lot is that there was no coordination
between the kids yelling like if there
was an excited scene and everyone's
trying to get attention like everyone
just yellows and you can't hear what any
of them are saying and like now if
there's like kids in a scene or anyone
in a scene there it's like a yelling a
scene like they kind of choreograph
who's gonna yell what and when and where
um and so that was just like a little
chaotic and it happened a lot and so
that was a weird thing that bothered me
it's not a big deal but other than that
I was like pleasantly surprised a lot of
people were like you've got to watch
this but also it probably doesn't hold
up well something that we grew up with
and it's got a lot of hype behind it but
it probably didn't age well and I had a
really fun time with it I recently
watched another older movie that has a
lot of hype that people say does hold up
well and I didn't think it did I'll
release that video later I'm scared too
so yeah it was really fun I thought it
held up better than I was ever expecting
and I have finally seen the Goonies
finally also I cos been sleeping next to
me this entire episode I'm actually a
little frightened to that his snoring is
going to pick up in the microphone see
snores really loud everyone's gonna be
so mad that I'm
but I'm still going to buy this been
Tamara's never seen by
by travelpod member